what in the hell has a drag queen ever
done to make you have so much respect
for them and admire them so much other
than put on makeup and and jump on the
floor and ride around and do sexual
things on stage would you want a
stripper or a porn star to influence
your child
don't miss this amazing opportunity from
Nature's blends to get your finest
premium black seed oil and shilajit to
get that energy levels back up check
them out now
guys so I came across a video of a
biological man who is a trans woman now
and this is what he had to say to
Jeffrey very ironically why is all the
people that have got some kind of weird
fetishes always called Jeffrey Jeffrey
Dahmer Jeffrey Epstein another Jeffrey
here's a message from this trans woman
to Jeffrey Marsh mellow this is what he
had to say I have no idea why you want
drag queens to read books to your
children what in the hell has a drag
queen ever done to make you have so much
respect for them and admire them so much
other than put on makeup and and jump on
the floor and ride around and do sexual
things on stage I have absolutely no
idea why you would want that to
influence your child would you want a
stripper or a porn star to influence
your child it makes no sense at all a
drag queen performs in a nightclub for
adults there is a lot of Filth that goes
on a lot of sexual stuff that goes on
and backstage there's a lot of nudity
sex and drugs so I don't think that this
is a an Avenue you would want your child
to explore to actually get them involved
in drag is extremely extremely
irresponsible on your part and I
understand you might want to look like
you're with it that you're cool that
you're woke that you're not a Nazi that
you're not a homophobe whatever whatever
it may be but you can raise your child
to be just a normal regular everyday
child without including them in gay
sexual things so we you guys heard that
for yourself I mean at least this person
is being just and honest the question
that needs to be asked is the following
what is it that they're doing so
productive so Innovative yeah so
inspiring so amazing that we have to
teach this to our kids this tells us
something very very very important
Muslims Christians Jews Hindus atheists
whoever you are who are listening to
this who you are in the same cause with
us as parents who have concern they do
not want us to accept them the way they
are
a big fat lie that's what it is it's a
big fat lie they want us to be just like
them and they know that if they target
the new generation they can do that
maybe not with us but if they can
brainwash our kids that is their
objective established they do not want
to stop at accept me the way you I am
because I've had discussions with gay
Muslims in the park I've spoken to them
I don't have any hostility towards them
or ill feeling towards them yes and I've
spoken to many people who are from the
homicide the LGBT community but the
point is the following it's not you
identifying however you want to be
identified yeah which we can agree to
disagree you want me to now accept your
facts yeah which are not facts okay you
want us to be like you you want our kids
to be like you that is the problem and
you are using this under the disguise of
we are a marginalized Community you know
and we are being a picked on and we are
being discriminated whatever those days
are over you can't come and see your
instruments those days are way over the
pop the problem right now is what you
will not stop at that you want our kids
and like you guys have said before why
would you go to a nursery a primary
school and go and do pole dancing and
twerking and do weird stuff this is
satanic I don't care what anybody says
and this shows us how if we don't have
religious boundaries that if you leave
the human mind too free without
boundaries this is what human beings
come to that is the point and I want to
thank this trans woman for speaking some
facts and put in some sense hopefully
into Jeffrey and God knows how much hate
he is going to get for speaking these
facts but the facts are in your face Mr
Jeffrey stay the hell away from our kids
and like I've said before we don't need
you as our family we will all rather be
orphans yes hashtag we will rather be
orphans till next time
hope this was a nice intellectual slap
in the face of Jeffrey and his likes and
his fanatic toxic radical fans stay away
from our kids
goodbye